JavaScript is a nearly perfect
programming language the only thing it's
missing is a good framework for building
websites now I've got a body count like
Will Chamberlain when it comes to
JavaScript Frameworks I've tried nearly
all of them and each one does some nice
tricks but none of them are marriage
material they all have their trade-offs
which I'll explain throughout this video
so you can understand what drives a
developer to the point of Madness where
they're left with no choice but to
create their own JavaScript framework
in my case God told me to do it allow me
to introduce you to Holy JS actually
never mind somebody already took that
name on npm let's go ahead and pivot to
the devil and call it flamethrower I
think that really captures the essence
of JavaScript programming now at this
point you may be wondering if I'm joking
the sad reality is no I did actually
create a game-changing platform for
building blazingly fast highly
interactive experiences on the jam stack
I also raised millions of dollars for my
company flamethrower Inc to Hype it up I
stole 99 of my ideas from other tools
but I'm going to tell you that
everything else sucks give it an MIT
license and then call you out if you try
to steal it so one day I might be as
successful as remix alright that part
was a joke about some Twitter drama but
what I really want to teach you in this
video is the trade-offs between all the
different major JavaScript Frameworks
out there here's the normal flowchart I
would go through when choosing a
framework for a new project the first
question to ask is is the project highly
interactive like are you building an app
with user authentication with all kinds
of data that can be manipulated by the
current user if the answer is no it
sounds like you're building a regular
website AI in which case you don't need
a JavaScript framework life will be much
easier with a static site generator like
Hugo or 11t and if you do end up needing
JavaScript you can always drop in
something like Alpine or petite view as
opposed to a heavyweight framework or an
even better option could be Astro which
generates static HTML but allows you to
bring in interactivity from any
framework as needed now if you are
building a highly interactive app the
next question you might ask is does it
need to be search engine friendly or
does it need to render HTML and data on
a server if the answer is no then just
use your favorite framework to build a
single page application if you don't
need to render content in advance for
search Bots then you can focus 100 on
the front end ux however if you do need
SEO then your next question will be how
often does the content change if it's
like a Blog where the content doesn't
change very often it sounds like you
have a jam stack application it
typically makes more sense to pre-render
your content and cache it on a CDN then
allow a JavaScript framework to hydrate
it and take over after the initial page
load Frameworks like next.js and spell
kit can do this in in SSG mode but you
also have tools like Gatsby that are
dedicated to this use case although it's
kind of fallen from Grace recently now
if your content is highly Dynamic and
constantly changing then you'll likely
need full server-side rendering to
regenerate the static content on the
server whenever a new request comes in
this is what tools like nexjs next and
spill kit are designed to do and if
you're not exactly sure how your project
is going to evolve I would default to a
full SSR framework
that gives you a simple framework for
choosing the right framework but things
can get a lot more complicated from here
what I'm building is a platform to host
my courses it requires user
authentication and is highly interactive
and also needs to have really good SEO
the content doesn't change all that
often so that would lead us to the jam
stack option I started working on the
project with spelled kit which is an
awesome framework but is more general
purpose and doesn't have a ton of
features for Content management compared
to something like Hugo that leads to the
question of how do I manage tons of
content one option is I could stick with
spell kit and just re-implement all
these content management features on my
own don't get me wrong I love
Reinventing the wheel as much as the
next JavaScript developer but one other
issue is that I'm worried these
Frameworks won't be fast enough when
rendering a lot of markdown the creator
of 11t made a good Benchmark comparing
them option b would be to pay for a
headless CMS like contentful or sanity
but then I have to add another paid
service to my stack strappy is another
good option that you can self-host but
then I have to manage a separate server
and database just to manage my content
what I really want to do is just write
all my content and work down and manage
it in a git repository GitHub is
actually an awesome free content
management system for developers
although that's not its intended use
that line of thinking takes me back to
static site generators which are the
best at handling markdown and templating
Astro seems like a perfect choice here
but it brings up one other question
which is how do I share data or state
between different routes on Astro you'll
notice that when you navigate you get a
full page load for each route that means
the JavaScript reboots and even if you
use something like Nano stores or
spelled stores the information from the
previous route is lost it's not like
next.js where the client-side router
takes over and renders the UI with
JavaScript on all routes after the
initial page load this can be a problem
if you're managing authentication state
with Json web tokens in something like
Firebase and want to show the current
user up in the nav bar along with some
data from a database that might update
in real time so basically that leads us
back to next.js or any other framework
that fully hydrates after the initial
page load there's also new Cutting Edge
Frameworks like quick and solid start
that could be good options in the future
but I just need to get this project done
is ASAP as possible and of course the
most efficient way to do that is to
build your own JavaScript framework the
question that led to this is how do I
take a static site ensure JavaScript
functionality and data between routes
with zero latency on the page transition
and without the need for a framework to
take over the entire Dom in other words
I want a spa-like router for static
sites and that's basically what I built
it has zero dependencies and relies
entirely on browser native technology
like fetch a long time ago when I first
started working as a web developer there
was a library called pjax that would
asynchronously fetch fragments of HTML
from your server and update the Dom
rather than do a full page reload this
approach evolved into a library called
turbo links which is still very popular
today and receives more npm downloads
than most JavaScript Frameworks out
there the way it works is when you click
on a link it prevents that default
Behavior then uses fetch to grab the
page you want to navigate to it swaps
out the body of the page then updates
the head with the delta or changes on
the new page that means if you already
executed JavaScript on the previous page
like a global State Management Library
it doesn't need to be re-executed on the
next page load that's really interesting
behavior and I'll explain why in just a
minute but was the main inspiration for
my framework well actually it's just a
library technically the reason I didn't
just use turbo links is because it's
rather large and does a bunch of stuff
that I don't really need and there's a
few special features that I wanted to
add to my library to create a truly
next-gen holistic platform one of the
biggest things that annoys me about
modern web development is that when
you're building a big content-driven
site 99 of the UI is static HTML that
doesn't do anything however the common
approach is to take this HTML and manage
it 100 in a JavaScript framework there
are some definite benefits to doing that
but it requires all kinds of special
tooling things like virtual Dom and
requires you to stay married to just one
framework as a polygamist I demand more
for my framework we can actually take an
entirely different approach that's
natively supported in all browsers using
web components a lot of people like to
talk [ __ ] about web components for
various reasons but basically it's just
a browser API for creating custom
elements that encapsulate their own
JavaScript and CSS there are Frameworks
dedicated to building web components
like lit and stencil but all the major
Frameworks can compile to web components
as well one awesome thing about web
components is that you can use them
anywhere like regular HTML elements you
can even use them in markdown without
any extra plugins or dependencies on top
of that you can use them between
Frameworks for example I could build a
web component with svelte and then
access it from a react and angular app
in my case web components are awesome
because I can use a static site
generator then add interactivity to my
templates by simply declaring my custom
elements it's kind of like the islands
architecture where you have islands of
interactivity but one thing to keep in
mind is that web components will never
be server rendered they're only rendered
on the client although interestingly you
can project server rendered content in a
web component which I think would be
perfectly indexable by search engines
now here's where things get really cool
when you combine web components with the
router they render instantly between
route changes what I have here is a
statically generated site with a counter
web component generated by spelled that
gets its data from a spelled store when
the router is disabled it does a full
page load and the current count is lost
when we go to the next page now if we
enable the router notice how the count
data is not lost between route changes
just like a single page application not
to mention the page transition feels
much faster for the end user in this
code base I have an 11t project inside
of which has an extra app directory that
contains a filter app configured to
compile to custom elements from a
development standpoint the only thing
you really need to do differently is
Define a tag for each component then you
export each component individually the
last thing I'm doing is starting the
flamethrower router by calling it as a
function the router has a couple of
extra features that you wouldn't find in
something like turbo links for one it
will find all of the visible links on
the page and automatically tell the
browser to pre-fetch them the browser
will automatically download these pages
in the background so they're ready to
render as soon as a user clicks on a
link that's made possible with
prefetched link tags and I also use the
intersection Observer API to only
pre-fetch the links that are visible on
the screen because those are the ones
the user is more likely to click in
other words as you scroll down it will
lazily pre-fetch the links that come
into view if you want to see the actual
latency between route changes set log to
true and it will add a timer to every
fetch operation it should be blazingly
fast like well under 100 milliseconds in
addition I threw in a little bonus
feature that takes advantage of the new
page transitions API this API isn't
supported in browsers yet and you'll
need to enable it with a flag but
basically it allows you to animate
natively between page transitions kind
of like you would expect in a native
mobile app as you can see by default it
does a Crossfade animation the bottom
line though is that this router has
allowed me to create my own little meta
framework using svelt compiled to web
components along with Hugo a static site
generator which gives me awesome CMS
features with extremely fast builds with
routing that feels like a single page
application that's pretty much it the
real question is who's coming with me
who's coming with me
who's coming with me this is a proven
technique and used on big sites like
dev2 with turbo but currently
flamethrower isn't meme status and I
wouldn't recommend using it in
production until it reaches Alpha I have
the luxury of doing weird experimental
stuff like this but if you're building a
serious app for yourself don't go
chasing waterfalls stick to the
libraries and Frameworks that you're
used to like next spell kit Astro and so
on now that I've hyped up my
game-changing JavaScript framework my
next step is to abandon it then ask for
donations via open Collective to start
an SEO link Farm which is the most
reliable way to fund open source I've
got to feed my family somehow thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one